oh
this is
yes
we are here today
thank you
uh
you
um
thank
very good
so
so
oh
oh
this is
good evening
my name is executive director
commissioner
presidential
to make making this evening possible
possible
and in a few moments you're here
to all of those former presidential
chancellors
to former moderators to members members
of our division international network
who have set their closest three am
tomorrow morning to tune in live
we thank
international network who have set their
clocks to 3 a.m
tomorrow morning to tune in live we
thank you with all our hearts
in 1987 paul kirk and frank farenkov
co-founded
the cpd i'd like to introduce the
co-chair
frank farinkop and his colleague are
also our co-chair ken wallock to start
this part of the program
thank you janet and thank you ladies and
gentlemen and welcome to the
health education campus case western
reserve in the
cleveland clinic and if you have not had
the opportunity yet
to go around and see this fantastic
facility you really should
it's just a great tribute to everyone
who's been involved with it
and it's so important to our nation to
say as janet
mentioned that this has been the most
challenging
time for this commission in its 33 years
of existence due to the coronavirus
problems uh so many people as janet
said are responsible we normally don't
come out when
my co-chairman and i come out and thank
people but we wouldn't be here today
if it had not been for them as we serve
as both the sponsor
and the producers of the debates
we have a crew of 65
people most of which have been with us
for years some of them go back to the
first debates
in 1988 and thanks
so much to united airlines
has stepped up to the plate and
graciously provided to fly
our whole crew from one site to another
throughout the rest of the term of these
debates so we have a great shout out for
united airlines
and anheuser-busch has been with us for
28 years as has the firm of trial
and mooring in washington dc
also special thanks to some people in
the network business
in the journalism business pentagram cbs
news radio and intercom
communications in the hotel
behind us the intercontinental there's a
tremendously large room
which is called the media filing center
there's only i guess is about 700
people in there today we usually have
three to five
thousand people in the media filing
center
and so with and that we've had
you can look around this audience we
normally have 900 people in the audience
you people are very fortunate to have
the opportunity to be
to be here tonight but the national
press club in washington dc
tonight is hosting a media filing center
for those journalists
in washington who couldn't be here
tonight and so we're very very thankful
for that many of you i see faces here
i've known him
in the audience before there will be in
the estimate
of most experts close to 120 million
people
watching this debate this evening it'll
be
on their tv sets it'll be on their
computers
it'll be on their ipads it'll be on
their iphones they're listening on the
radio
and those 120 million or however it
works out to be
deserve to be able to listen and observe
on this
stage tonight these two men put forth
the reasons
why they should be elected president of
the united states
and that's why it's been our history in
the general election debates
that we urge our audiences not to clap
not to yell to sit silently
and not interfere with these people who
are trying to
ascertain who they're going to vote for
now exactly at nine o'clock you're going
to hear
a lot of noise behind you if you turn
around now you can take a quick look
there's three on this side and three on
this side and these are the major nets
and at nine sharp you're going to hear
them all go on air
and so it makes a little noise so don't
be afraid by it
and i must at the end really thank the
people that you saw
on your way here tonight and you see
around here
the united states secret service the
federal bureau of investigation
department of homeland security and
clemson's university media forensic hub
that is working with us and monitoring
the the web and social media
so there's so many people to thank and
these men and women and the police
that you saw outside the local police
department who work so hard to keep us
all safe
and keep our nation safe so thanks now
i'd like to introduce by the newest
member of the leadership team
ken wallach who for 25 years ran the
national democratic institute of
international affairs ndi
and we're really excited to have him
join us as co-chair
i joined frank janet and fellow board
members
including yvonne howe and jane harman
who are with us tonight in welcoming you
to the 23rd
presidential debate sponsored and
organized by the commission on
presidential debates
as frank said i am the commission's
newest co-chair
and as the new kid on the block i am
proud to work alongside those
who have been engaged in this initiative
for the past
33 years these debates have now become
an integral part of our political
process
a view shared by the most important
judge
the american electorate but as
significant as debates have become here
they can be even more consequential
overseas
where the commission in partnership with
the national democratic institute has
helped organize more than 400
debates in 45 nations
in post-conflict countries and in new
and emerging democracies
debates have helped level the playing
field in places where only one party has
ruled
they have forced discussion on policy
issues not personalities
and yes they have promoted comity among
political
competitors and that's comity with the t
and this effort has spawned the
establishment of a global support
network
of similar debate organizations from
nearly 40 countries
dub debates international
now i would call your attention to the
commission sponsored
debate watch 2020 and the participation
by watch groups in all 50 states
from a hair salon owner in cleveland
heights hosting
10 employees to the atlantic council
hosting a global audience
for more than 80 thousand the goal of
the debate watch is not to say
who won or who lost
but to share views with those who agree
and those who don't to listen
respectfully to each other's opinions
we are pleased that the commission's
longest-standing
supporters judy and peter kovaler
are in the audience tonight
for for 32 years
the judy and peter blum kovler
foundation
has given its trust to the
non-partisan mission of the commission
we are deeply grateful for their belief
in our work
and their extraordinary contribution to
the 2020 debates
it is now my distinct honor to introduce
dr tom mihalovic president
of the cleveland clinic and barbara
snyder
president of case western reserve
university
thank you very much
good evening on behalf of cleveland
clinic
it is my pleasure to welcome you to the
city of cleveland
tonight you join us in the beautiful
samson pavilion
of the health education campus at
cleveland clinic
we share this campus with our partners
from case western
reserve university this building is very
special to us
it was opened just a year ago
as a place for students medical nursing
and dental
to begin their professional journeys by
learning together as teams
at that time as we were opening this
campus
none of us could have managed to imagine
that we would soon face
a worldwide pandemic when it happened
we converted this building into a kobe
19
search hospital the space in which you
are sitting
right now had 1 000 hospital beds
we called it the hope hospital
thankfully
the surge did not come in ohio yet
tonight
this building serves another purpose
in support of our democracy and it is a
historic occasion for us
and for our city we are proud
to support the commission on
presidential debates as their health
security advisor
we at cleveland clinic and our 70 000
caregivers have been serving
the health needs in cleveland since 1921
nearly 100 years yet
our organization and our caregivers have
never shown brighter
than during this pandemic the pandemic
has brought out the best
of our organization and our caregivers
of our city and our state
through partnership and collaboration we
see how much we can accomplish when we
work together
and we are particularly proud of our
partnership with case western reserve
university
with that i would like to introduce my
colleague and friend
president of case western reserve
university
barbara snyder thank you tom
case western reserve is honored to
co-host this presidential debate with
our partners at cleveland clinic
and delighted to show you this
spectacular space we created together
research has long shown that team-based
healthcare leads to better outcomes for
patients
yet nearly every academic institution
continues to prepare students
in separate buildings literally in silos
yet after spending years learning only
with students from the same profession
doctors with doctors nurses with nurses
and so on
they are suddenly expected to know how
to work in teams
once they get their diplomas we knew
there had to be a better way
and together we built it when not filled
with a stage
and seats this atrium gives hundreds of
students
a huge open space to study talk
and simply be together the entire
building provides mult
multiple spaces for them to come
together supported by an academic model
that emphasizes
opportunities to learn with and from one
another
add state of the art technology and we
know our graduates will be uniquely
prepared to excel in team-based care
and ultimately to lead it along the way
cleveland clinic and case western
reserve also learned
from one another among the most valuable
lessons
was that through collaboration we
achieved far more than either of us
could achieve alone
thank you tom for being such a wonderful
colleague and friend
thank you to the commission for giving
both of our organizations
the opportunity to be part of this
historic event
it is a true privilege to contribute to
our nation's democratic process
and thank you all for watching
thank you tom and barbara very much most
valuable player
award for this evening goes to toby
cosgrove we couldn't have done it
without you
thank you one housekeeping bit
for the audience uh as soon as this
debate is over if you will please remain
seated you will be shown
which way to exit
and please stay where you are until that
happens
i would like to now introduce chris
wallace
the moderator of this evening's debate
[Applause]
[Applause]
um
okay
foreign
life
happens
no
good evening from the health education
campus of case western reserve
university
and the cleveland clinic i'm chris
wallace of fox news and i welcome you to
the first of the 2020
presidential debates between president
donald j
trump and former vice president joe
biden
this debate is sponsored by the
commission on presidential debates
the commission has designed the format
six roughly
15 minute segments with two-minute
answers from each candidate to the first
question
then open discussion for the rest of
each segment
both campaigns have agreed to the polls
for the record i decided the topics and
the questions in
each topic i can assure you none of the
questions has been
the advisor to the commission for all
four debates
as a precaution both campaigns have
agreed the candidates
will not shake hands at the beginning of
tonight's debate
the audience here in the hall has
promised to remain silent no cheers
no boos or other interruptions so we and
more importantly you
can focus on what the candidates have to
say
no noise except right now as we welcome
the republican nominee president trump
and the democratic nominee vice
president biden
gentlemen a lot of people have been
waiting for
this night so let's get going our first
subject is the supreme court
president trump you nominated amy coney
barrett over the weekend
to succeed the late ruth bader ginsburg
on the court you say the constitution is
clear about your obligation and the
senate's
to consider a nominee to the court vice
president biden you say that this is an
effort by the president and republicans
to jam through an appointment and what
you call
an abuse of power my first question to
both of you tonight
why are you right in the argument you
make
and your opponent wrong and where do you
think
a justice barrett would take the court
president trump in this first segment
you go first two minutes
thank you very much chris i will tell
you very simply we won the election
elections have consequences we have the
senate
we have the white house and we have a
phenomenal
nominee respected by all top top
academic good in every way good in every
way
in fact some of her biggest endorsers
are very liberal people from notre dame
and other places so i think she's going
to be fantastic we have plenty of time
even if we did it after the election
itself i have a lot of time after the
election as you know
so i think that she will be outstanding
she's going to be
as good as anybody that has served on
that court we really feel that
we have a professor at notre dame highly
respected by all said she's the single
greatest
student he's ever had he's been a
professor for a long time at a great
school
and we just we won the election and
therefore we have the right
to choose her and very few people
knowingly
would say otherwise and by the way the
democrats they wouldn't even think about
not doing it if they had the only
difference is they'd try and do it
faster
there's no way they would give it up
they had merit garland
but the problem is they didn't have the
election so they were stopped
and probably that would happen in
reverse also definitely would happen in
reverse
so we won the election and we have the
right to do it chris
president trump thank you um same
question to you vice president biden you
have two minutes
well first of all um thank you for doing
this and
looking forward to this mr president i
uh
the american people have a right to have
a say in who the supreme court nominee
is and that say occurs
when they vote for a united states
senators and when they vote for
the president united states they're not
going to get that chance now because
we're in the middle of an election
already
election has already started tens of
thousands of people have already voted
and so the thing that should happen is
we should wait
we should wait and see what the outcome
of this election is because that's the
only way the american people get to
express
their view is by who they elect as
president and who they elect as vice
president
now what's at stake here is the
president's made it clear
he wants to get rid of the affordable
care act he's been running on that
he ran on that and he hasn't been
governing on that
he's in the supreme court right now
trying to get rid of
the the affordable care act which will
strip
20 million people from having
insurance health insurance now if if
they if it goes into court
and and uh the justice and i have
nothing
i'm not opposed to the justices she
seems like a very fine person
but she's written before she went in the
bench which is her right
that she thinks that the affordable care
act is not constitutional
the other thing is on the court and if
it's struck down what happens
women's rights are fundamentally changed
once again
a woman could be helped pay more money
because she has a pre-existing condition
of pregnancy
we were able to they were able to charge
a woman more for the same exact
procedure a man did
gets and that ended when we in fact
passed the affordable care act
and there's a hundred million people
have pre-existing conditions
and they'll be taken away as well those
pre-existing conditions the
insurance companies are going to love
this and so it's just not appropriate
to do this before this election if he
wins
the election and the senate is democrat
a republican
and he goes forward if not we should
wait until february
there aren't a hundred million people
with pre-existing conditions
as far as the say is concerned the
people already had their say
they okay justice ginsburg said very
powerfully very strongly
at some point ten years ago or so
she said a president in the senate is
elected for a period of time but a
president is elected for four years
we're not elected for three years i'm
not elected for three years
so we have the senate we have a
president elected to the next during
that period of time
during that period of time we have an
opening
i'm not elected for three years i'm
elected for four years
and 100 million people jill the hundred
million people is totally wrong i don't
know where you got that number
the bigger problem that you have is that
you're going to
extinguish 180 million people with their
private health care that they're very
happy that's simply not true well you
said no you're going to socialist not
going to socialize
we're now under gentlemen we're now into
open discussions
yes i agree go ahead vice president
number one uh
he he knows that uh what i proposed what
i proposed
is that uh we expand obamacare
and we increase it we do not wipe any
and
one of the big debates we had with 23 of
my colleagues trying to win the nominee
that i
won were saying that biden wanted to
allow people to have private insurance
still
they can they do they will under my
proposal not what you've said
and it's not what that party is saying
that is simply the party doesn't say
your party wants to go socialist
party is socialist right now i am and
they're going to dominate you joe you
know that
i am the democratic party right now the
platform of the democratic party
is what i in fact approved of what i
approved of now here's the deal the deal
is that
it's going to wipe out pre-existing
conditions and by the way
the 20 the 200 million the 200 000
people that have died on his watch
they're how many of those and have
survived well there's seven million
people that contracted covet
what does it mean for them going forward
if you strike down
the affordable care act joe you've had
308
000 military people dying because you
couldn't provide them proper health care
in the military so don't tell me about
it happy to talk about that and if you
were
here you wouldn't be 200 it would be two
million people
because you were very late on the draw
you didn't want me to ban china
which was heavily infected you didn't
want me to ban all right
we are going to talk about covet in the
next segment but go ahead
let me finish the point is that the
president also
is opposed to roe v wade that's on the
ballot as well
and the court in the court and so that's
also at stake
right now and so the election is all you
don't know what's on the ballot
why is it in the ballot because
it's not on the ballot it's on the
ballot in the court i think so
from the court well there's nothing
happening there donald
trump you don't know her view on roe v
wade i don't know well all right all
right let's talk
i would we got a lot to unpack here
gentlemen we got a lot of time so
uh on health care and then we'll come
back to roe v
wade all right mr president the supreme
court will hear
a case a week after the election in
which the trump administration along
with 18 state attorneys general
are seeking to overturn that's right
obamacare to end obamacare you have
spent the last
because they want to give good health if
i may ask
questions sir good health care over uh
the last four years you have promised
to repeal and replace obamacare but you
have never in these four years
come up with a plan a comprehensive plan
to replace obamacare of course i have
well i'll get rid of the individual i'm
going to give you excuse me
i got rid of the individual mandate
which was a big chunk
of that is absolutely a big thing that
was the worst part of obamacare
chris that was the worst part
and i would like you to let me ask my
question and then you can answer
you in the course of these four years
have never come up with a comprehensive
plan
to replace obamacare and
just this last thursday you signed a
largely symbolic executive order to
protect people
with pre-existing conditions five days
before this debate
so my question sir is what is the trump
health care plan
well first of all i guess i'm debating
you not him but that's okay i'm not
surprised let me just tell you something
that
there's nothing symbolic i'm cutting
drug prices i'm going with favorite
nations which no president has the
courage to do because you're going
against big pharma
drug prices will be coming down 80 or 90
you could have done it during your 47
year period in government but you didn't
do it
nobody's done it so we're cutting health
care all of the things that we've done
i'll give you an example insulin it's
going to it was destroying families
destroying people the cost
i'm getting it for so cheap it's like
water you want to know the truth
so cheap take a look at all of the drugs
that what we're doing prescription drug
prices
we're going to allow our governors now
to go to other countries to buy drugs
because
they pay just a tiny fraction discussion
sir you'll be happy i'm about to pick up
on one of your points
to ask the vice president which is he
points out that you would like to add
a public option to obamacare and the
argument that he makes
now the republicans make is that that is
going to end
private insurance it is and well if i
ask you the question says by the way it
will end
private insurance and create a
government takeover of healthcare it
does not it's only for those people who
are so poor
they qualify for medicaid they can get
that
free in most states except governors who
want to deny
people or poor medicaid anyone who
qualifies for medicare would
excuse me medicaid would automatically
be enrolled
in the public option the vast majority
of the american people would still
not be in that option number one so you
agree
with bernie sanders far left on the
manifesto
that gives you socialized medicine look
hey are you still not gonna
listen to him the fact of the matter is
i beat bernie sanders
not pretty much i beat him a whole hell
of a lot i'm here i'm here standing
facing you
would have left two days early you would
have lost every price oh he knows how to
support
tuesday you've got to look very long
here's the deal i got very luck gaming
very lucky tonight as well and tonight
i'm going to make sure
because here's the deal here's the deal
the fact is that everything he's saying
so far
is simply a lie i'm not here to call out
his lies everybody
knows he's a liar but you i just want
him to tell you
that i i i want to make sure last night
first today
i want to meet you president can you let
him finish sir no he doesn't know how to
do that
he has you know christ you picked to be
surprised
the wrong guy the wrong night at the
wrong time listen you agreed with
bernie sanders
there is no manifesto number please let
him speak mystery number two
just lost the left number two i i you
just lost the left
you agreed with bernie sanders on a plan
absolutely
he is not for any help for people
needing health care because his because
he in fact
already has cost 10 million people their
health care
that they had from their employers
because of his recession
number one number two there are 20
million people
getting health care through obamacare
now that he wants to take
it away he won't ever look in eye and
say that's what he wants to do
take it away oh i want to give numbers
better health care at a much lower price
because
he doesn't know how he doesn't know how
to already fixed it he has never offered
he fixed
obamacare is no good we made it better
and i had a choice to make very early on
we took away the individual mandate we
guarantee pre-existing conditions but
took away the individual mandate
listen this is the way it is and that
destroyed
that they shouldn't even call it
obamacare then i had a choice to make do
i let my people run it really well
or badly if i run it badly they'll
probably blame him but they'll blame me
but more importantly i want to help
people
okay i said you've got to run it so well
that's what and i just had a meeting
with them they said the problem is no
matter how well
you run obamacare it's a disaster
it's too expensive premiums are too high
that it doesn't work
we do want to get rid of it we want to
get rid of that i understand that
but i have to i have to give you roughly
equal time please
let the vice president talk he has no
plan for health care yes we do sends
please
he sends out wishful thinking he has
executive orders have no
power he hasn't lowered drug costs for
anybody he's been promising a health
care plan
since he got elected he has none like
almost everything else he talks about
he does not have a plan he doesn't have
a plan
and the fact is this man doesn't know
what he's talking about all right
i have one final question for you sure
uh mr vice president
if senate republicans we were talking
originally about the supreme court here
if senate republicans go ahead and
confirm
justice barrett uh there has been talk
about ending the filibuster or even
packing the court
adding to the nine justices there you
call this a distraction by the president
but in fact it wasn't brought up by the
president
it was brought up by some of your
democratic colleagues in i'm saying the
congress
so my question to you is you have
refused in the past to talk about it
are you willing to tell the american
people tonight whether or not you will
support
either ending the filibuster or packing
the court whatever position i take in
that that'll become the issue the issue
is the american people should speak
you should go out and vote you're in
voting now
vote and let your senators know how
strong you feel
let vote now make sure you in fact
let people know he doesn't we're a
senator i'm not going to answer the
question because yeah
because the question is the question is
point justice
radical left will you listen who is on
your list joe
this is on youtube gentlemen
we have ended this segment we're going
to move on to the second segment that
was really a
productive segment wasn't it
keep yapping man the people understand
yeah 47 years you've done nothing they
understand
all right the second subject is coveted
19 which is an awfully serious subject
so
let's try to be serious about it we have
had more than seven
million cases of coronavirus in the
united states and more
than 200 000 people have died even
after we produce a vaccine experts say
that it could be months
or even years before we come back to
anything
approaching normal my question
for both of you is based on what you
have said
and done so far and what you have said
you would do
starting in 2021 why should the american
people
trust you more than your opponent
to deal with this public health crisis
going forward
in this case the question goes to you
first sir
two minutes uninterrupted good luck
two hundred thousand dead as you said
over seven million infected in the
united states
we in fact have five percent or four
percent of the world's population
twenty percent of the deaths forty 000
people
a day are contracting covet in addition
to that
about between 750 and a thousand people
today are dying
when he was presented with that number
he said it is what it is
well it is what it is because you are
who you are
that's why it is the president has no
plan he hasn't laid out anything he knew
all the way back in february how serious
this crisis was
he knew it was a deadly disease what did
he do
he's on tape is acknowledging he knew it
he said he didn't tell us or give people
a warning of it
because he didn't want to panic the
american people you don't panic
he panicked in addition to that what did
he do
he went in and he we were insisting that
the chinese the
people we had on the ground in china
should be able to go to wuhan and
determine for themselves
how dangerous this was he did not even
ask she to do that he told us what a
great job
she was doing he said we owe him a debt
of gratitude
for being so transparent with us and
what did he do then
he then did nothing he waited and waited
and waited he still doesn't have a plan
i laid out back in march exactly what we
should be doing
and i laid out again in july what we
should be doing
we should be providing all the
protective gear posts we should be
providing the money the house has passed
in order to be able to go out and get
people the help they need to keep their
businesses open
open schools that cost a lot of money
you should get out of your bunker and
get out of the sand trap and get in
in your golf course and go in the oval
office and bring together the democrats
republicans and fund what needs to be
done now to save
lives so if we would have listened to
you you have two minutes sir
if we would have listened to you the
country would have been left wide open
millions of people would have died not
200 000 and one person is too much it's
china's fault it should have never
happened they stopped it from going in
but it was china's fault
and by the way when you talk about
numbers you don't know how many people
died in china
you don't know how many people died in
russia you don't know how many people
died in india they don't exactly give
you a straight count just so you
understand
but if you look at what we've done i
closed it and you said he's xenophobic
he's a racist and he's xenophobic
because you didn't think i should have
closed our country wait a minute it says
two minutes you didn't think we should
have closed our country because you
thought it was too
it was terrible you wouldn't have closed
it for another two months
by my doing it early in fact dr fauci
said
president trump saved thousands of lives
many of your democrat governor said
president trump did a phenomenal job we
worked with the governor oh really go
take a look
the governor said i did a phenomenal job
most of them
said that in fact people that would not
be
necessarily on my side said that
president trump did a phenomenal job
we did we got the gowns we got the masks
we made the ventilators you wouldn't
have made ventilators and now we're
weeks away from a vaccine
we're doing therapeutics already fewer
people are dying when they get sick
far fewer people are dying we've done a
great job
the only thing i haven't done a good job
and that's because of the fake news
no matter what you say to them they give
you a bad press on it's just fake news
they give you good press they give me
bad press because that's the way it is
unfortunately but let me just tell you
something i don't care i've gotten used
to it
but i'll tell you joe you could never
have done the job that we did you don't
have it in your blood you could have
never done that yet
i know how to do the job i know how to
get the job well you didn't do very well
in swine flu
h1n1 you were a disaster you're your own
chief
14 000 people died not two hundred
thousand there was a very economically
recession you might have
we didn't shut down the economy this is
his economy that's being he's shut down
the reason it's shut down is because
look you folks at home how many of you
get up this morning
and had an empty chair at the kitchen
table because someone died of covet
how many of you were in a situation
where you lost your mom or dad and you
couldn't even speak to them that
a nurse holding a phone up so you could
in fact say goodbye would have lost far
how many people
far
his own cdc director says we could lose
as many as another
200 000 people between now and the end
of the year and he held him he said
if we just wear a mask we can save half
those numbers just just to mask
and by the way in terms of the the whole
notion of a vaccine
we're for a vaccine but we i don't trust
him at all nor do you i know you don't
what we trust is a scientist you don't
trust us johnson
let me move on to questions about the
future because you both have touched on
one of the
two of the questions i'm going to ask uh
focusing on the future first president
trump
you have repeatedly either contradicted
or been at odds with some of your
government's own top scientists the week
before last
the head of the centers for disease
control dr redfield said it would be
summer before the vaccine would become
generally available
to the public you said that he was
confused
and mistaken those are your two words
but
dr slowy the head of your operation worf
speed
has said exactly the same thing are they
both wrong well i've spoken to the
companies and we can have it a lot
sooner it's a very political thing
because people like this
would rather make it political than save
lives it is a very political thing
i've spoken to pfizer i've spoken to all
of the people that you have to speak to
we have great modern
johnson and johnson and others they can
go faster than that by a lot
become very political because the left
or i don't know if i call it
i don't know what the head of your
operation warp speed doctor i disagree
with him yeah no i disagree with both of
them
and he didn't say that he said it could
be there but it could also be much you
know
i had him in my office two days he
talked about the summer sir before it's
generally available
he said it's a possibility that we'll
have the answer
before november 1st it could also be
generally available well we're going to
deliver it right away we have the
military all set up logistically they're
all set up
we have our military that delivers
soldiers and they can do 200 000 a day
they're going to be this is the same man
it's all set up
by easter this would be gone away by the
warm weather it'd be gone
miraculous like a miracle and by the way
maybe you could inject some bleach in
your arm and that would take care of it
this is that the same know that i
would have said sarcasm so here's the
deal this man is talking about a vaccine
every serious every serious company is
talking about
maybe having a vaccine done by the end
of the year but the distribution of that
vaccine
will not occur until sometime beginning
or the middle of next year to get it out
if we get the vaccine and pray god we
will
may god mr vice president i want to pick
up though
i want to pick up on this question
though you say the public
can trust the scientists but they can't
trust president trump in fact you said
that again tonight
your running mate senator harris goes
further saying the public health experts
quote
will be muzzled will be suppressed given
the fact that polls already show
that people are concerned about the
vaccine and are reluctant to take it
are you and your running mate senator
harris contributing to that fear
no more than the question you just asked
him you pointed out
he puts pressure and disagrees with his
own scientist
but you're saying you can't even
understand harris is saying you can't
trust the side
well no no you can't trust the scientist
he said she didn't say that you can't
she said the public health experts will
that's what he's going to try to do but
there's millions of scientists there's
thousands of scientists out there
like here at this great hospital that
don't work for him
their job doesn't depend on him that's
not
they're the people there and by the way
to the scientists that are in charge by
the way they will have the vaccine very
seriously
do you believe for a moment what he's
telling you in light of all the lies
he's told you about
the whole issue relating to covet he
still hasn't even acknowledged
that he knew this was happening knew how
dangerous was going to be
back in february and he didn't even tell
you
he's on record as saying it he panicked
or he just looked at the stock market
one of the two
because guess what a lot of people died
and a lot more going to die unless he
gets a lot smarter a lot quicker
mr president did you use the word smart
so you said you went to delaware state
but you forgot the name of your college
you didn't go to delaware state you
graduated
either the lowest or almost the lowest
in your class don't ever use the word
smart with me
don't ever use that word oh give me your
because you know what there's nothing
smart about you joe 47 years you've done
this let's add this to ben
you would have had let me just tell you
something joe if you would have had
the charge of what i was put through i
had to close
the greatest economy in the history of
our country and by the way now it's
being built again see here let's
get to the economy in the next segment
sir okay it's going up fast okay
when it comes to how the virus has been
handled so far
the two of you have taken very different
approaches and this is going to affect
how the virus is handled going forward
by
whichever of you ends up becoming the
next president i want to quickly go
through several of those reopenings
vice president biden you have been much
more reluctant than president trump
about reopening the economy and schools
why sir
because he doesn't have a plan if i were
running i know how what the plan is
you've got to provide these businesses
the ability to have the money to be able
to reopen with the ppe
as well as with the sanitation they need
you have to provide them
pelosi okay please just shush for a
minute
by the way nancy pelosi and schumer they
have a plan
he won't even meet with them the
republicans won't meet with the senate
but he he says he sits in his golf
course and
i mean literally think about it you
probably play more than i do jim
what about those question of reopenings
and the fact he wants to shut down
this country and i want to keep it open
and we did a great job wait a minute let
me shut you down for a second joe just
for one second
we want to he wants to shut down the
country we just went through it we had
to because we didn't know anything about
the disease now we found
that elderly people with heart problems
and diabetes and different problems are
very very vulnerable we learned a lot
young children aren't
even younger people aren't we've learned
a lot but he wants to shut it down
more people will be hurt by continuing
if you look at pennsylvania if you look
at certain states
that have been shut down they have
democrat governors all one of the
reasons they're shut down is because
they want to keep it shut down until
after the election
november
those states are not doing well that are
shut down
responding you have begun
to increasingly question the
effectiveness
of masks as a disease preventer and in
fact recently you have cited
the issue of of waiters touching their
mass and touching plates
are you questioning they'll be asking
okay
you have to understand if you look i
mean i have a mask right here i put a
mask on it
you know when i think i need it tonight
as an example everybody's had a test
and you've had social distancing and all
of the things that you have to but
i wear masks when needed when needed i
wear a mask
okay let me ask i don't have to i don't
wear mess like him every time you see
him he's got a mask he could be speaking
200 feet away from me he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
i will say vice president go ahead sir
look
the way to open businesses is give them
the wherewithal to be able to open
we provided money the kind of i was
asking a sir about masks
well mask must make a big difference his
own head of the cdc said if we just wore
mass between now
if the everybody wore masks in social
distance between now and january
we'd probably save up to a hundred
thousand lives
it matters and they've also said the
opposite they've also said no
no serious person said the opposite
looks serious
dr fauci said the answer is very strong
a minute left and then there's actually
are not good then he changed his mind he
said
i'm not okay with masks i want to ask
you both about one last subject because
your different approaches has even
affected the way that you have
campaigned
president trump you're holding large
rallies with crowds packed together
thousands of people i would say outside
yes sir agreed
uh vice president biden you are holding
much smaller
uh events with nobody will show up
people would
what's wrong with you nobody shows up to
israel all right in any case
why you holding the big rallies why you
not
you goes first sir because people want
to hear what i have to say i mean what
are you doing
to the president and i'll have 25 35 000
people show up
at airports we use airports
we have a lot of people well so far we
have had no problem whatsoever it's
outside
that's a big difference according to the
experts
and we do them outside we have
tremendous crowds
as you see i mean every and literally on
24 hours notice
and joe does the circles and has three
people someplace okay
by the way did you just did you one of
the last big rallies he has
and a reporter came up to him to ask him
a question he said no no no
stand back put on your mask put on a
mask
have you been tested i'm way i'm way far
away from those other people
that's what he said i can't i'm going to
be okay he's not worried about you
he's not worried about the people out
there breathing in one another we've had
no negativity
no negative effect we've had no negative
effect and we've had
thousand right people wanted israelis
just quickly finish up because i want to
move on to our next yes i would he's
been totally irresponsible the way in
which he has handled
the social distancing and people wearing
masks basically encourage them not to
all right he's a fool if you could get
the crowds
you would have done the same thing but
you can't nobody can gentlemen can we
move on to the accusers
settlement can we move on to the economy
yes the economy
is i think it's fair to say recovering
faster than expected from the shutdown
in the second quarter the unemployment
rate fell to 8.4
last month the federal reserve says the
hit
to growth which is going to be there is
not going to be nearly as big
as they had expected president trump you
say we are in a v-shaped
recovery vice president biden you say
it's more of a k-shape
what difference does that mean to
the american people in terms of the
economy president trump in this
segment you go first so we built the
greatest economy in history we closed it
down because of the china plague when
the plague came in we closed it down
which was very hard
psychologically to do he didn't think we
should close it down and he was wrong
and again two million people would be
dead now instead of
still 204 thousand people is too much
one person is too much should have never
happened from china
but what happened is we closed it down
and now we're reopening and we're doing
record business
we had 10.4 million people in a
four-month period that we've
put back into the workforce that's a
record the likes of which nobody's ever
seen before
and he wants to close down he will shut
it down again he will destroy this
country
you know a lot of people between drugs
and alcohol and
depression when you start shutting it
down you take a look at what's happening
at some of your democrat-run states
where they have these
tough shutdowns and i'm telling you it's
because they don't want to open it one
of them came out
last week you saw that oh we're going to
open up on november 9th why november 9th
because it's after the election
they think they're hurting us by keeping
them closed they're hurting people
people know what to do they can social
distance they can wash their hands they
can wear masks
they can do whatever they want but they
got to open these states up
when you look at north carolina when you
look and these governors are under siege
pennsylvania michigan and a couple of
others
you've got to open these states up it's
not fair you're talking about almost
it's like being in prison
and you look at what's going on with
divorce look at what's going on with
alcoholism and drugs it's a very very
sad thing
and he'll close down the whole country
this guy will close down the whole
country
and destroy our country our country is
coming back incredibly well
setting records as it does it we don't
need somebody to come in and say let's
shut it down
all right you're two minutes sir we're
now moved to you
as i as i said posing the question the
president says it's a v-shaped recovery
you say it's a k-shaped
recovery what's the difference the
difference is
millionaires and billionaires like him
in the middle of a cover crisis
have done very well another billionaires
of ray have
made another 300 billion dollars because
of his
profligate tax proposal and
he only focused on the market but you
folks at home
you folks living in scranton and
claymont and all the small towns and
working-class towns in america
how old are you doing it this guy paid
well total of 750 dollars in taxes
wait wait no sir it's just two i
understand you've agreed to the two
minutes so please let him have it
i get my time back the fact is that he
is in fact
worked on this in a way that he's going
to be the first president united states
to leave office having fewer jobs in his
administration
than when he became president fewer jobs
than when he came from first one in
american history
secondly the people who have lost their
jobs
are those people who have been on the
front lines those people who have been
saving our lives those people who have
been out there
dying people who've been putting
themselves in the way to make sure
that we could all try to make it and the
idea that he is
insisting that we go forward and open
when you have almost half the states in
america with a significant increase
in covert deaths and covert cases in the
united states of america
and he wants to open it up more why does
he want to open it up why doesn't he
take care of the america you can't fix
the economy
until you fix the covet crisis and he
has no
intention of doing anything about making
it better for you
all at home in terms of your health and
your safety
schools why aren't schools open because
it costs a lot of money to open them
safely
you know they were going to give his
administration going to give the
teachers and school
students masks and then they decided no
couldn't do that because it's not a
national emergency
not a national emergency they've done
nothing to help
small businesses nothing they're closing
one in six is now gone
he ought to get on the job and take care
of the needs of the american people
so we can't open safe all right your
time is up sir we are going to get to
i have to respond to this well you both
had two minutes sir
excuse me he made a statement people
want their schools
no people want their schools open they
don't want to be shut down
they don't want their estate shut down
they want their restaurants i look at
new york it's so
sad what's happening in new york it's
almost like a ghost town
and i'm not sure it can ever recover
what they've done in new york people
want their places open
they want to get back to their lives
people they'll be careful
but they want their schools i'm the one
that brought back football by the way i
brought back
big ten football it was me and i'm very
happy to do it
and all right people of ohio are very
proud of me and
you're not going to get about that
gentleman we're going to get to your
economic plans going forward in a moment
but first mr president
as you well know there's a new report
that in 2016 the year you were elected
president and 2017
your first year as president that you
paid 750
a year in federal income tax each of
those
years i know that you pay
a lot of other taxes but i'm asking you
the specific question
is it true that you paid 750 in
federal income taxes each of those two
years i paid
millions of dollars in taxes millions of
dollars
of income tax and let me just tell you
there was a story in one of the papers
i paid 38 million one year
i paid 27 million show us your tax
returns
i went uh you'll see it as soon as it's
finished you'll see it you know if you
want to do
go to the board of elections there's 118
page or so report
that says everything i have every bank i
have i'm totally
under leveraged because the assets are
extremely good
and we have a very we have a i built it
i'm asking you a specific question which
is
let me tell you i understand all of that
no mr president i'm asking you a
question
will you tell us how much you paid in
federal income
taxes in 2016 and 2017.
millions of dollars you paid millions of
dollars millions of dollars
millions of dollars and you'll get to
see it and you'll get to see it
but let me chris let me just tell you
something that
it was the tax laws i don't want to pay
tax before i came here
i was a private developer i was a
private business people like every other
private person unless they're stupid
they go through the laws and that's what
it is he passed a tax bill
that gave us all these privileges for
depreciation
and for tax credits we build the
building and we get tax credits like the
hotel
on pennsylvania avenue you get a massive
which by the way was given to me
by the obama administration if you can
believe that
now the man got fired right after that
happened but vice president biden you
want to respond yeah i do want to
respond
look the tax code that made him
put him in a position that he pays less
tax than a school teacher
makes on the money a school teacher
makes is because
of him take he says he's smart because
he can take advantage of the tax
code and he does take advantage of the
tax code that's why
i'm going to eliminate the trump tax
cuts and we're going to we're
going to eliminate those taxes and make
sure that we invest in the people who in
fact
need the help people out there need help
but why didn't you do it over 20 in the
last 25
because you years president of screwing
things up you were a senator
you're the worst president america has
ever had
let me just tell you joe i've done more
in in 47 months i've done more than
you've done in 47 years joe
we've done things that you never even
thought about including fixing the
broken military that you gave me
taking care of you mr president we're
talking about the economy i'd like to
ask you
about your plans going forward because
mr vice president your economic plan
if you were to be elected president uh
focuses a lot on big government big
taxes
big spending i want to focus first on
the taxes
you propose more than four trillion
dollars over a decade in new taxes
on individuals making more than four
hundred thousand dollars a year
and on corporations president trump says
that that kind of a
increase in taxes is going to hurt the
economy as it's just coming out of a
recession well just take a look at what
as the
the analysis has been on by wall street
firms points out that
my my economic plan would create seven
million more jobs in his in four years
number one
and number two it would create an
additional one trillion dollars in
economic growth because it would be
about
buying american that we have to we're
going to make this federal government
spend
600 billion dollars a year on everything
from ships
to steel to buildings and the like and
under my proposal
we're going to make sure that every
penny of that has to be made
by a company respectively so i'm talking
about taxes not
spending well by the way i'm going to
eliminate significant number of the tax
i'm going to
make the the the corporate tax 28
it shouldn't be 21 you have 19
companies 91 companies federal i mean in
the
fortune 500 who don't pay a single penny
in tax making billions of dollars why
didn't you do it billions of dollars
because obama because you in fact passed
that
that was your tax proposal i got it done
and you know what happened yeah you got
it down our economy boom
it's never been the economy president
let me
mr president let me pick up on that you
would continue
your free market approach lower taxes
more
deregulation correct not lower taxes
american people
but in but in obama's you talk about the
economy booming
it turns out that in obama's final three
years as president
more jobs were created a million and a
half more jobs
than in the first three years of your
presidency they had the slowest
recovery since night economic recovery
since
1929 it was the slowest recovery
also they took over something that was
down here all you had to do was turn on
the lights and you pick up a lot
but they had the slowest economic
recovery since 1929 let me tell you
about the stock market
when the stock market goes up that means
jobs it also means 401ks
if you got in if you ever became
president with your ideas you want to
terminate my tax
my taxes i'll tell you what you'll lose
half of the companies that have poured
in here
will leave and plenty of companies that
are already here they'll leave for other
places have they will leave
and you will have a depression the likes
of which you've never seen
look we inherited the worst recession
short of a depression in american
history i was asked to bring it back
we were able to have an economic
recovery that created the jobs you're
talking about
we handed him a booming economy he blew
it it wasn't he blew it
he wasn't booming it was the weakest
request
wait wait is it is it fair to say he
blew it when
in fact when there was record on low
unemployment yeah before covet
yeah but because what he did even before
covert manufacturing went in the hole
manufacturing went in the whole excuse
number two number three they said they
would take no you're a number two no
chris chris they said it would take a
miracle
to bring back manufacturing i brought
back seven hundred thousand jobs
they brought back nothing they gave up
on manufacturing
standard fare i'm the guy he totally
gave up on manufacturing all right
we brought back i was asked to bring
back chrysler and general motors we
brought him back right here in the state
of ohio
in michigan he blew it they're gone he
blew it
and in fact they're gone ohio had the
best year it's ever had last year
michigan had the best year they've ever
had it's not many car companies came in
from germany from japan
went to michigan and went to ohio
they're not happening and they didn't
come in
mr vice president and so you take a look
at what he's actually done
he's done very little his trade deals
are the same way
he talks about these great trade deals
you know he talks about the art of the
deal china's
made perfected the art of the steel we
have a higher deficit with china now
than we did before
we have the highest deficit trade
deficit china within mexico
china ate your lunch joe and no wonder
your son goes in and he
takes out he takes out billions of
dollars
takes out billions of dollars to manage
he makes millions of dollars
and also while we're at it why is it
just out of curiosity
the mayor of moscow's wife gave your son
three and a half million dollars
what did he do to deserve it what did he
do with baristas none
of them deserve a hundred and eighty
three thousand dollars
not none of that is true
totally discredited totally discredited
and by the way
well wait he can't get three and a half
million dollars joe this advice
he got three president that is not true
really
mr president you it's an it's an open
discussion please
it's a fact well there's no you have
raised an issue let there's been
a president answer discredited 183 000
a month with no experience in
my energy did nothing wrong at first i
think he did mr president
he doesn't want to let me answer because
he knows i have the truth his position
has been totally
thoroughly discussed by everybody well
by the media by our allies by the world
bank
by everyone as discredited matter of
fact
matter of fact mr president who
testified under oath
so let me ask you this
he testified under oath in his
administration said i did my job and i
did it very well
every well i'll give you the list of the
people who tested it
they've you've already fired most of
them because they did a good job some
people don't know but here's
with you guys wait a minute you get the
final word well it's hard to get any
word in with this clown excuse me this
hey let me just say no no i'm mr
president
that is simply why did he deserve three
and a half million from moscow look
here's the deal we want to talk about
families
and ethics i don't want to do that i
mean his family we could talk about all
night
his family's my family my family
coming down and helping us with
government and that's such a right
mr president single one of them this is
not about
my family or his family it's about your
family the american people
he doesn't that's not true it doesn't
want to talk about
what you need you the american people
it's about you that's what we're talking
about all right
that's the end of the segment
the answer to the question is no ukraine
no i sir
with a billion dollars you know what
you're waiting not
why should i be different than the two
of you so here's the data good point
we have five six segments we have ended
that segment we're going to go to the
next segment
in that segment you each are going to
have two uninterrupted moments
in those two interrupted minutes mr
president you can say anything you want
i'm going to ask a question about race
but if you want to answer about
something else go ahead
but we i think that the country would be
better served
if we allowed both people to speak with
fewer interruptions i'm appealing to you
sir to do that
well and him too well frankly you've
been doing more interruptions that's all
right but he does plenty
well less than sir less than plenty no
less than you have
let's please continue on the issue of
race vice president biden you say
that president trump's response
to the violence in charlottesville three
years ago
when he talked about very fine people on
both sides
was what directly led you
to launch this run for president oh yeah
sure president
trump you have often said that you
believe you have done
more for black americans than any
president with the possible
exception of abraham lincoln my question
for the two of you
is why should voters trust you rather
than your opponent
to deal with the race issues facing this
country over the next four years
vice president biden you go first it's
about equity
inequality it's about decency it's about
the constitution
and we have never walked away from
trying to quit
require equity for everyone equality for
the whole of america
but we've never accomplished it but
we've never walked away from it like he
has done
it is true the reason i got in the race
is with those people close your eyes
remember what those people look like
coming out of the fields carrying
torches
their veins bulging speeding and just
spewing anti-semitic
bile and accompanied by the ku klux klan
a young woman got killed
and they asked the president what he
thought he said they were very fine
people on both sides no president has
ever said anything
like that it is now second sir
second point i'd make to you is that
when
floyd was killed when mr floyd was
killed there was a peaceful protest in
front of the white house
what did he do he came out of his bunker
had the military
do use tear gas on him so he could walk
across to a church and hold up a bible
and then what happened after that the
bishop of that very church
said that it was the disgrace the
general who was with him said
he only all he ever wants to do is
divide people not unite people at all
this is a president who has used
everything as a dog whistle
to try to generate racist hatred racist
division
this is a man who in fact you talk about
helping african-americans
one in one thousand african-americans
has been
killed by the coronavirus and if he
doesn't do something quickly by the end
of the year
one in 500 will have been killed one in
500 african-americans
this man this man is the as a savior of
african-americans
this man cares at all this man's done
virtually nothing look the fact is that
you have to
look at what he talks about you have to
look at what he did
and what he did has been disastrous for
the african-american community
so president trump you have two minutes
why should
americans trust you over your opponent
to deal with racism did a crime bill
1994 where you call them super predators
african-americans the super predators
and they've never forgotten it they've
never forgotten it jefferson
no sir it's his two minutes so you did
that and they call you a super predator
and i'm letting people out of jail now
that
you have treated the african-american
population community you have treated
the black community
about as bad as anybody in this country
you did the 199 and that's why
if you look at the polls i'm doing
better than any republican has done in a
long time
because they saw what you did you call
them super predators
and you've called them worse than that
because you look back at your testimony
over the years you've called them a lot
worse than that as far as the church is
concerned
and as far as the generals are concerned
we just got the support of 200
mil 250 military leaders and generals
total support law enforcement almost
every law enforcement
group in the united states i have
florida i have texas
i have ohio i have every
excuse me portland the sheriff just came
out today and he said i support
president trump i don't think you have
any law enforcement you can't even say
the word law enforcement because if you
say those words
you're going to lose all of your radical
left supporters and why aren't you
saying those words
why don't you say the words law
enforcement because you know what if
they called us in portland
we would put out that fire in a half an
hour but they won't do it because
they're run by radical left democrats
if you look at chicago if you look at
any place you want to look seattle
they heard we were coming in the
following day and they put up their
hands and we got back seattle
minneapolis we got it back joe because
we believe in law and order but you
don't
the top 10 cities in just about the top
40 cities
are run by democrats in many cases
radical left and they've got you wrapped
around their finger joe
to a point where you don't want to say
anything about law and order
and i'll tell you what the people of
this country want
and demand law and order and you're
afraid to even say it
all right i want to i want to return to
the question of race
vice president biden after the grand
jury in the brianna
taylor case decided not to charge any of
the police
with homicide you said it raises the
question quote
whether justice could be equally applied
in america do you believe
that there is a separate but unequal
system of justice for
blacks in this country yes there is
there's just there's
systemic injustice in this country in
education
and work and in in law enforcement and
and the way in which it's enforced but
look the vast majority of police
officers are good decent honorable men
and women
they risk their lives every day to take
care of us but there are some bad apples
and when they occur when they find them
they have to be
sorted out they have to be held
accountable they have to be held
accountable
and what i'm going to do as president
united states is call a
together an entire group of people at
the white house
blow everything from the civil rights
groups to the police officers the police
chiefs
and we're going to work this out we're
going to work this out so we change the
way in which we have more transparency
in when these things happen these cops
aren't happy to see what happened to
to george floyd these cops aren't happy
to see what happened to
brianna taylor most don't like it but we
have to have a system
where people are held accountable when
and by the way violence and response is
never appropriate
never appropriate peaceful protest is
violence is never
appropriate right now what is peaceful
protest when they run through the
members of the town
and burn down your stores and kill
people
president trump i'd like to continue
with the issue of race i promise we're
going to get to the issue of law and
order
in a moment this month your
administration
directed federal agencies to end racial
sensitivity training that addresses
white privilege or critical race theory
why did you decide to do that to end
racial sensitivity training
and do you believe that there is
systemic racism in this country sir i
ended it because it's racist i ended it
because a lot of people were complaining
that they were
asked to do things that were absolutely
insane
that it was a radical revolution that
was taking place
in our military uh in our schools
all over the place and you know it and
so does everybody else
and he would know what was wrong with
racial sensitivity training
if you were a certain person you had no
status in life it was sort of a reversal
and if you look at the people we were
paying people hundreds of thousands of
dollars
to teach very bad ideas and frankly very
sick ideas
and and really they were teaching people
to hate
our country and i'm not going to do that
i'm not going to allow that to happen
we have to go back to the core values of
this country
they were teaching people that our
country is a horrible place it's a
racist place
and they were teaching people to hate
our country and i'm not going to allow
that
to happen vice president biden nobody's
doing that he's just
he's the racist you just don't here's
the deal i know a lot more about you
the fact is that there is racial
insensitivity people have to be made
aware
of what other people feel like what
what insults them what is demeaning to
them
it's important to people know they don't
want to many people don't want to
hurt other people's feelings but it's
amazing makes a big difference
it makes a gigantic difference in the
way a child is able to grow up and have
a self
a sense of self-esteem it's a little bit
like how
this guy and and his friends look down
on so many people
they look down their nose on people like
irish catholics like me and grow up in
scranton they look down on people who
don't have money they look down on
people
who are of a different faith they look
down on people who are a different color
in fact we're all americans the only way
we're going to bring this country
together
is bring everybody together there's
nothing we cannot do
if we do it together we can take this on
and we can defeat
racism president i mean president
trump's sir during the obama
biden administration there was
tremendous division
there was hatred you look at uh ferguson
you look at
you go to very many places look at
oakland look what happened in oakland
look what happened in baltimore look
what happened or
frankly it was more violent than what
i'm even seeing now but the reason
this is that the democrats that run
these cities
don't want to talk like you about law
and order violence you still haven't
mentioned
are you in favor of law and order i'm in
favor of law you follow
where people get treated fairly and the
fact of the matter is violent crime went
down
17 15 in our administration
all right it's gone up on his watch went
down much more he has
all right we're we're done mr president
mr president every record mr president
you're gonna be very happy because we're
not gonna talk about law and orders
because we had trouble with democratic
democratic-run
cities that's exactly my question there
has been a dramatic increase in
homicides in america
this summer particularly and you often
blame that on democratic
mayors and democratic governors but in
fact there have been equivalent
spikes in republican-led cities like
tulsa and fort worth
so the question is is this really a
party issue
i think it's a party issue you can bring
in a couple of examples but if you look
at chicago what's going on in chicago
where
53 people were shot and eight died shot
if you look at new york where it's going
up like nobody's ever seen anything the
numbers are going up 100 150
200 percent uh crime it is
crazy what's going on and he doesn't
want to say law and order because he
can't
because he'll lose his radical left
supporters and once he does that it's
over with but
if he ever got to run this country and
they ran it the way he would want to run
it
we would have our suburbs would be gone
by the way
our suburbs would be gone and you would
see problems like
he would have no suburb unless you took
a wrong turn oh i know celebrities
i was raised in the suburbs this is not
1950.
all these dog whistles and racism don't
work anymore suburbs are by and large
integrated
there's many people today driving their
kids to soccer practice and or to
black and white and hispanic in the same
car as there have been any time
in the past what's what really is a
threat to the suburbs and their safety
is his failure to deal with covet
they're dying in the suburbs
his failure to deal with the environment
they're being flooded
they're being burned out because his
refusal to do anything
that's why the suburbs are interested i
do want to talk about this issue of law
and order though and
in the joint recommendation that came
from the
biden bernie sanders task force you
talked about
quote reimagining policing
first of all what does reimagining
policing mean and do you support
it let me if i might finish the question
what does reimagining policing mean
and do you support the black lives
matter
uh call for uh
for community control of policing look
what i support is the police having the
opportunity to deal with the problems
they face
and i'm not totally opposed to defunding
the police officers
as a matter of fact police local police
the only one defunding in his budget
calls for a 400 million dollar cut in
local law enforcement assistance
they need more assistance they need when
they show up for a 9 11 call to have
someone with them as a psychologist
or psychiatrist to keep them from having
to use force
and be able to talk people down we have
to have community policing like we had
before
where the officers get to know the
people in the communities
that's when crime went down it didn't go
up it went down
and so we have to be that's not what
they're talking about chris
that's not where that is he's talking
about defunding the police that is not
true
he doesn't have any law support he has
no law enforcement that's not true
almost that's not look who do you have
name one group that supports you
name one group that came out and
supported you go ahead i think
we have time we don't have time to do it
all right
one law enforcement group that came back
gentlemen i think i'm going to i'm going
to take back the moderators
and i want to get to another subject
which is the issue of protests in many
cities
that have turned violent in portland
oregon especially we had a
more than a hundred straight days of
protests
which i think you would agree you talk
about peaceful protests many of those
turned into riots
mr vice president you say that people
who commit crimes
should be held accountable the question
i have though is as the democratic
nominee and earlier tonight you said
that you are the democratic party right
now
have you ever called the democratic
mayor of portland or the democratic
governor of oregon and said
hey you've got to stop this bring in the
national guard
do whatever it takes but you'd stop the
days and months of violence
in portland i don't hold public office
now
i am a former vice president i've made
it clear i've made it clear in my public
statements
that the violence should be prosecuted
it should be prosecuted and anyone who
commits it but you've never called for
the people
the leader excuse me sir you had never
called for the leaders in portland
and in oregon to call us bring in the
national guard
and knock off a hundred days of riots
they can in fact
take care of it if he just stay out of
the way oh really here oh really
young man in the middle of the street
they shot him and for three days
president trump
through anything i had interrupted the
us martial
business go ahead sir and by the way you
know his own former spokesperson said
you know riots and chaos and violence
helpless cause
that's what this is all about i don't
know who said that i do
who i think kellyanne conway i don't
think she said she said that
and so here's that all right but here's
the point the point is that
that's what he is keeps trying to rile
everything up
he doesn't want to calm things down
instead of going in
and talking to people and saying let's
get everybody together figure out how to
deal with this
what's he do he just pours gasoline in
the fire
constantly and every single solitary
okay and and to
end this button up this segment i'm
going to give you a minute to answer sir
you have repeatedly criticized i have to
answer his stuff
you have to stay late wait
you know if you want to switch seats we
could very quickly we could do that
it would be over there'd be no problem
okay but they don't want to accept the
national guard you have repeatedly
criticized the the vice president for
not specifically calling out
antifa and other left-wing extremist
groups
but are you willing tonight to condemn
white supremacists
and militia groups and to say that they
need to stand down and not add to the
violence in a number of these cities as
we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland
i would say almost everything i see is
from the left wing
not from the right what are you what do
you what are you saying i'm i'm willing
to do anything i want to see peace then
do it sir
say it do it say it do you want to call
him
what do you want to call him give me a
name give me a white surprise
stand back and stand by but i'll tell
you what
i'll tell you what somebody's got to do
something about antifa and the left
because this is not a right-wing problem
this is
your administration tells you the truth
is it has a bad idea
i tell you what you have no idea antifa
is a danger all right gentlemen we're
now moving on to the trump and botany
records and they'll overthrow you when a
president
i'm going to ask a question when the
president seeks a second term
it is generally a referendum on his
record but vice president biden you like
to quote one of your dad's
sayings which is don't compare me to the
almighty
compare me to the alternative and in
this case sir
you are the alternative looking
at both of your records i'm going to ask
each of you
why should voters elect you president
over your opponent
in this segment president trump you go
first two minutes
because there has never been an
administration or president
who has done more than i've done in a
period of three and a half years
and that's despite the impeachment hoax
and you saw what happened today with
hillary clinton where it was a whole big
con job but despite going through all of
these things where i had to fight
both flanks and behind me and above
there has never been an administration
that's done what i've done the greatest
before covet came in the greatest
economy in history lowest employ
unemployment numbers
everything was good everything was going
and by the way
there was unity going to happen people
were calling me for the first time in
years they were calling and they were
saying it's time maybe and then what
happened we got hit but now we're
building it back up again
a rebuilding of the military including
space force and all of the other things
a a fixing of the the va which was a
mess
under him 308 000 people died because
they didn't have proper health care he
it was a mess and we now got a 91
approval rating at the va our vets we
take care of our vets
but we've rebuilt our military the job
that we've done and i'll tell you
something some people say maybe the most
important
by the end of the first term i'll have
approximately
300 federal judges and court of appeals
judges 300
and hopefully three great supreme court
judges
justices that is a record
the likes of which very few people and
you know one of the reasons i'll have so
many judges
because president obama and him left me
128
judges to phil when you leave office you
don't leave any judges that's like you
just don't do that
they left 128 openings and if i were a
member of his party
because they have a little different
philosophy i'd say if you left
us 128 openings you can't be a good
president
you can't be a good vice president but i
want to thank you because it gives us
almost
it'll probably be above that number by
the end of this term
300 judges it's a record looking at both
your records
why should voters elect you president as
opposed to president trump you have two
minutes uninterrupted
under this president we become weaker
sicker
poor more divided and more violent
when i was vice president we inherited a
recession
i was asked to fix it i did we left him
a booming economy
and he caused the recession with regard
to being weaker
the fact is that i've gone head-to-head
with putin
and made it clear to him we're not going
to take any of his stuff he's putin's
puppy he still refuses to even say
anything to putin about
the bounty on the heads of american
soldiers your son no no
million dollars and by the way mr price
wait a minute mr president your campaign
agreed
to both sides would get two minute
answers uninterrupted well your your
side agreed to
it and why don't you observe what your
campaign agreed to as a ground rule okay
sir
he never keeps his words no no no i'm
not outside
that was a rhetorical question can you
go ahead back 30 seconds
yeah yes you may have all right go ahead
so
thirdly we're poor the billionaires have
gotten much
much more wealthy by a tune of over four
three to four hundred billion dollars
more
just since covent you in the home you
got
less you're in more trouble than you
were before
in terms of being more violent when we
were in office there were 15 percent
less
violence in america than there is today
he's president united states
it's on his watch and with regard to
more divided
the nation can't stay divided we can't
be this way
and speaking of my son the way you talk
about the military
the way you talk about them being losers
and being
and and just being suckers my son
was in iraq he spent a year there
he got he got the bronze star he got the
conspicuous service medal
he was not a loser he was a patriot
and the people left behind there were
heroes
and i resent you're talking like are you
talking about i'm talking about my son
beau biden you're talking i don't know
i don't know bo i know hunter hunter got
thrown hunter got thrown out of the
military
he was thrown out dishonorably
discharged that's not true
he wasn't cocaine use and he didn't have
it
until you became vice president what do
you mean
he made a fortune in ukraine in china in
moscow that is simply various of the
players true
my son my son
like a lot of people like a lot of
people we know at home had a
drug problem he's overtaken it he's he's
he's fixed it he's worked on it and i'm
proud of him but why was he out of my
head
we've already been through this i think
the american people would rather hear
about more substantial
well you know as the moderator sir i'm
going to make a judgment call here
three and a half million dollars from
the mayor of moscow
i think through the dominant report is
totally i was credited
mitt romney on that committee said it
wasn't worth taxpayers money that report
is written for political reasons you
know
i'd like to talk about climate change
joe and i okay
the forest fires in the west are raging
now they have burned
millions of acres they have displaced
hundreds of thousands of people when
state officials there blame the fires on
climate change mr president you said i
don't think
the science knows over your four years
you have pulled the us out of the paris
climate accord
you have rolled back a number of obama
environmental
records what do you believe about the
science of climate change
and what will you do in the next four
years to confront it
i want crystal clean water and air i
want
beautiful clean air we have now the
lowest carbon if you look at
our numbers right now we are doing
phenomenally
but i haven't destroyed our businesses
our businesses aren't put out of
commission if you look at the paris
accord it was a disaster from our
standpoint and people are actually
very happy about what's going on because
our businesses are doing well as far as
the fires are concerned
you need forest management in addition
to everything else the forest floors are
loaded up with trees
dead trees that are years old and
they're like tinder and
leaves and everything else you drop a
cigarette in there the whole forest
burns down
you've got to have forest management
what are you doing what do you believe
about the science of climate
change sir uh i believe that we have to
do everything we can to have immaculate
air immaculate water and do whatever
else we can that's good you know we're
planting a billion trees
the billion tree project and it's very
exciting believe that that
human pollution gas greenhouse gas
emissions contributes to the global
warming
i think a lot of things do but i think
to an extent yes i think to an extent
yes but i also think
we have to do better management of our
forests every
year i get the call california's burning
california is burning if that was
cleaned
if that were if you had forest
management good
forest management you wouldn't be
getting those calls you know in europe
they live their forest cities they call
forest cities
they maintain their forest they manage
their forests
i was with the head of a major country
it's a forest city
he said sir we have trees that are far
more they they ignite
much easier than california there
shouldn't be that problem i spoke with
the governor about i'm getting along
very well with the governor
but i said you know at some point you
can't every year have
hundreds of thousands of acres of land
just burned to the ground
but that's burning down because of a
lack of sir if you believe
in the science of climate change why
have you rolled back the obama
clean power plan which limited carbon
emissions in power plants why have you
relaxed because it was driving energy
prices through the sky why have you
relaxed fuel economy
standards that are going to create more
pollution from cars well not really
because what's happening is the car is
much less expensive and it's a much
safer car
and you're talking about a tiny
difference and then what would happen
because of the cost of the car
you would have at least double and
triple the number of cars purchased we
have the old slugs out there that are 10
12 years old
if you did that the car would be safer
it would be much cheaper by
3 500 california they've simply taken a
lot of cars off the market because
people would be able to afford a car
now so and by the way we're going to see
how that turns out but a lot of people
agree with me many people
the car has gotten so expensive because
they have computers all over the place
for an extra little bit okay of gasoline
and
and i'm okay with electric cars too i
think i'm all for electric cars i've
given big incentives for electric cars
but what they've done in california is
just crazy
vice president biden i'd like you to to
respond to the president's climate
change record but i also want to ask you
about a concern you proposed two
trillion dollars in green
jobs you talk about new limits not
abolishing but new limits on fracking
ending the use of fossil fuels to
generate electricity by 2035
and zero net emission of greenhouse
gases by 2050
the president says a lot of these things
would tank the economy and cost millions
of jobs he's absolutely wrong
number one number two if in fact when
our during our administration the
recovery act i was able i was in charge
able to bring down the cost
of renewable energy to cheaper than or
as cheap as
coal and gas and oil nobody's going to
build another
coal-fired plant in america no one's
going to build another oil-fired plant
in america
they're going to move to renewable
energy number one number two
we're going to make sure that we are
able to take the federal fleet and turn
it into a fleet that's
run on their electric vehicles making
sure that we can do that we're going to
put
500 000 charging stations and all of the
highways that we're going to be building
in the future
we're going to build a economy that in
fact is going to provide for
the ability us to take 4 million
buildings and make sure that they in
fact are
weatherized in a way that in fact
they'll emit significantly less gas and
oil because the heat will not be going
out
there's so many things that we can do
now to create
thousands and thousands of jobs we can
get to net
zero in terms of energy production
by 2035 not only not costing people jobs
creating jobs
creating millions of good paying jobs
not 15 bucks an hour
but prevailing wage by having a new
infrastructure that in fact
is green and the first thing i will do i
will rejoin
the paris accord i will join the paris
accord because with us out of it look
what's happening
it's all falling apart and talk about
someone who has no
no relationship to with foreign policy
brazil the rainforest of brazil
are being torn down are being ripped
down more
more carbon is absorbed in that
rainforest than every bit of carbon
that's admitted in the united
states instead of doing something about
that i would be gathering up and making
sure we had to come
the countries of the world coming up
with 20 billion dollars say here's 20
billion dollars
stop stop tearing down
the forest and if you don't then you're
going to have significant
economic consequences what about the
argument that president trump basically
says
that you have to balance environmental
interests
and economic interests and he's drawn
his line
well he hadn't drawn a line he still for
example make sure that we he wants to
make sure that
methane is not a problem we can you can
now emit more methane without it being a
problem
methane this is a guy who says that you
don't have to have mileage standards for
automobiles that exist now
this is the guy who says that well the
fact that
it's it's all true and here's talking
about the green new deal and it's not 2
billion
or 20 billion as you said it's 100
trillion dollars i'm talking about they
want to rip down buildings
and rebuild the building it's the most
redundant
is not where airplanes are out of
business where two car systems are out
where they want to take out the cows too
you know that's not true either right
this is a this is a 100 trillion that's
more money
than our country could make in a hundred
years if we're not
the case all right let me let me let me
just because i actually wait a minute
sir i actually
have studied your plan and it includes
upgrading four million buildings
weatherizing two million homes over four
years
building one and a half million energy
efficient
homes so the question becomes some
the president is saying i think some
people who support the president would
say
that sounds like it's going to cost a
lot of money and hurt the economy what
it's going to do it's going to create
thousands and millions of jobs
good paying jobs let him finish sir he
doesn't know how to do that
100 billion the fact is it's going to
create million
good paying jobs and these tax
incentives to people
for people to weatherize what she wants
to get get rid of
it's going to make the economy much
safer look how much we're paying now
to deal with the hurricanes with the
deal with by the way he has an answer
for hurricanes he said
maybe we should drop a nuclear weapon on
them they may i never said that
he did she made it up uh and here's the
deal you make up
we we're going to be in a position where
we can create
hard hard good jobs by making sure the
environment
is clean and we all are in better shape
we spend
billions of dollars now billions of
dollars
on floods hurricanes rising seas
we're in real trouble look what's
happening just in the midwest with these
storms that come through and wipe out
entire sections and counties
in iowa they didn't happen before
they're because of global
warming we make up 15 of the world's
problem we in fact but the rest of the
world we've got to get them to come
along that's what we have to get back
into back into the paris accord
all right gentlemen wait a minute chris
so why didn't he do it for 47 years you
were vice president why didn't you get
the world
china sends up real dirt into the air
russia does
india does they all do we're supposed to
be good and by the way
he made a couple of statements the green
new deal is a hundred trillion dollars
that is not
my plan that's free well we want to
rebuild every building my plan i want to
rebuild everyone i knew anything about
it he made a statement about the
military he said i said something about
the military
he and his friends made it up and then
they went with it i never said it okay
he called the volunteer vice president
he said yesterday stupid please stop i
would never say
go ahead mr vice president answered
his q his final question the final
question is i can't remember which of
all is rantings
i'm having a little trouble myself but
uh and
about the economy and about this
question of what it's going to cost
the the economy i mean the green new
deal and the idea of what what
your environmental changes will do the
green new deal
will pay for itself as we move forward
you're not going to build
plants that in fact are great polluting
plants but you're going to build a brand
new deal
pardon me you support no i don't support
the green new deal don't oh well that's
a big statement
i support you just the radical left i
said
i support the biden plan that i put
forward
okay the biden plan which is different
than what he
calls the radical green new deal all
right gentlemen final segment
election integrity as we meet tonight
millions of americans
are receiving mail-in ballots or going
to vote early
how confident should we be that this
will be a fair election and what are you
prepared to do
over the next five plus weeks because
it'll not only be to election day but
also
counting some ballots mail-in ballots
after election day
what are you prepared to do to reassure
the american people that the next
president
will be the legitimate winner of this
election
in this final segment mr vice president
you go first prepared to let people vote
they should go to iwillvote.com
decide how they're going to vote when
they're going to vote and what means by
which they're going to vote
his own homeland security director and
as well as the fbi director says there
is no
evidence at all that mail and ballots
are a source of
of being manipulated and cheating they
said that
the fact is that there are going to be
millions of people because of covet
that are going to be voting by mail and
ballots like he does by the way
he sits behind the resolute desk and
sends his ballot to florida
number one number two we're going to
make sure that those people who
want to vote in person are able to vote
because enough poll watchers are there
to
make sure they can socially distance the
polls are open on time
and their polls stay open until the
votes are counted and this is all about
trying to dissuade people from voting
because he's trying to con
to scare people into thinking that it's
not going to be legitimate
show up and vote you will determine the
outcome of this election
vote vote vote if you're able to vote
early in your state
vote early if you're able to vote in
person vote in person vote whatever way
is the best way for you
because you will he cannot stop you from
being able to determine the outcome of
this election
and in terms of whether or not when the
votes are counted and they're all
counted
that will be accepted if i win that will
be accepted if i lose it'll be accepted
but by the way
if in fact he says he's not sure what
he's going to accept
well let me tell you something it
doesn't matter because if we get the
votes
it's going to be all over he's going to
go he can't stay in power
it won't happen it won't happen so vote
just make sure you understand you have
it in your control to determine
what this country is going to look like
the next four years is it going to
change you get four more years of these
mr president two minutes so when i
listened to joe
talking about a transition uh there's
been no transition from when i won i won
that election
and if you look at crooked hillary
clinton if you look at all of the
different people
there was no transition because they
came after me trying to do a coup
they came after me spying on my campaign
they started from the day i won
and even before i won from the day i
came down the escalator with our first
lady
they were a disaster they were a
disgrace to our country
and we've caught them we've caught them
all we've got it all on tape we've
caught them all and by the way you gave
the idea for the logan act against
general flynn
you better take a look at that because
we caught you in a sense and
president obama was sitting in the
office he knew about it too so don't
tell me about a free transition
as far as the ballots are concerned it's
a disaster
a solicited ballot okay
solicit it is okay you're soliciting
you're asking they send it back you send
it back
i did that if you have an unsolicited
they're sending millions of ballots all
over the country
there's fraud they found him in creeks
they found some with the name
trump just happened to have the name
trump just the other day in a waste
paper basket
they're being sent all over the place
they sent two
in a democrat area they sent out a
thousand ballots everybody got two
ballots
this is going to be a fraud like you've
never seen the other thing
it's nice on november 3rd you're
watching and you see who won the
election
and i think we're going to do well
because people are really happy with the
job we've done
but you know what we won't know we might
not know for months
because these ballots are going to be
all over take a look at what happened in
manhattan take a look
at what happened in new jersey take a
look at what happened in virginia and
other places
they're not losing two percent one
percent which by the way is too much an
election could be won or lost with that
they'll listen 30 and 40 percent it's a
fraud and it's a shame and can you
imagine where they say
uh you have to have your ballot in by
november 10th
november 10th that means that's seven
days
after the election in theory should have
been announced okay we have made your
states with that
sir all run by definitely that's just
two minutes all run by democrats
president trump's a rig you're going to
be able to continue
you have been charging for months and
mail-in balloting is going to be a
disaster you say it's rigged
i said it's going to lead to fraud but
in 2018 in the last midterm election
31 million people voted mail-in
voting that was a quarter more than a
quarter of all the voters that year
cast their ballots by mail now that
millions of mail-in
ballots have gone out what are you going
to do about it
and are you counting on the supreme
court
including a justice barrett to settle
any dispute
i think i'm counting on them to look at
the ballots definitely i don't think
well i hope we don't need them
in terms of the election itself but for
the ballots i think so
because what's happening is incredible i
just heard i read today where at least
one percent of the ballots for 2016 were
invalidated they they take them we don't
like them we don't like them
they throw them out if there are
millions of ballots going on what you do
is you go and vote you do a solicited
ballot no no that's okay i know where
are you going
i'm asking you about the fact that
millions of people you go and vote
you go and vote like they think like
they used to in the
millions of people you either do chris a
solicited ballot where you're sending it
in they're sending it back and you're
sending
they have mailman with lots of it did
you see what's going on take a look at
west virginia mailman selling the
ballots
they're being sold they're being dumped
in rivers this is a horrible thing for
our country there is no this is not
there is no
this is not going to end well this is
not
vice president five states in fact i've
had mail-in ballots
for the last decade or more five
including two republican states
and you don't have to solicit the ballot
it's sent to you
it's sent to your home what we're saying
is they're saying is that it has to be a
postmark
by the time by election day if it
doesn't get in until the
seventh eighth nine it still should be
counted
he's just afraid of counting the votes
because you're
vice president biden the biggest problem
in fact over the years with mail-in
voting
has not been fraud historically it has
been
that sizable numbers sometimes hundreds
of thousands of ballots are thrown out
because they have not been properly
filled out or there is some other
irregularity or they must be through
the deadline so the question i have is
are you concerned
that the supreme court with a justice
barrett will settle any dispute i am
concerned that any court would settle
this because here's the deal
when you when you file when you get a
ballot
and you fill it out you're supposed to
have an affidavit if you didn't know you
have
someone say that this is me you should
be able to if in fact you can verify
that you when the before the ballot is
thrown out
that's sufficient to be able to count
the ballot because someone made a
mistake
and not dotting the correct eye who they
voted for
testify say who they voted for
say it's you that is totally legitimate
all right
election workers are prohibited
currently by law eight states
from even beginning to process ballots
even take them out of the envelopes and
flatten them until election day that
means that it's likely because there's
going to be a huge increase
in mail-in balloting that we are not
going to know
on election night who the winner is that
it could be days it could be weeks
until we find out who the the new
president is so i
first for you sir finally for the for
the vice president i hope neither of you
will interrupt the other
will you urge your supporters to stay
calm
during this extended period not to
engage in any
civil unrest and will you pledge tonight
that you will not declare victory
until the election has been
independently certified
president trump thank you very much my
supporters to go into the polls
and watch very carefully because that's
what has to happen i am urging them to
do it
as you know today there was a big
problem in philadelphia they went in to
watch they were
called poll watchers a very safe very
nice thing they were thrown out they
weren't allowed to watch
you know why because bad things happen
in philadelphia bad things
and i am urging i am marriaging my
people i hope it's going to be a fair
election if it's a fair election
i am 100 on board but if i see
tens of thousands of ballots being
manipulated i can't go along with that
and i'll tell you what is that from a
common sense does that mean you're going
to tell your other people
it means you have a fraudulent election
you're sending out 80 million ballots
they're not equipped these people aren't
equipped to handle it
number one number two they cheat they
cheat
hey they found ballots in a waste paper
basket
three days ago and they all had the name
military ballots they were military
they all had the name trump on them vice
president i think that's good
vice president biden final question for
you will you urge your supporters to
stay calm
while the vote is counted and will you
pledge not to declare victory
until the election is independently
certified yes and here's the deal
we count the ballots as you pointed out
some of these ballots in some states
can't even be opened
until election day and if there's
thousands of ballots going to take
time to do it and by the way our
military they've been voting
by ballots first since at the end of the
civil war
in effect and that's and that's what's
happened going to happen why was it not
why is it for them somehow not
fraudulent
it's the same process it's honest
no one has established at all that there
is
fraud related to male imbalance that
somehow it's a fraudulent process it's
already been established
take a look at caroline maloney's race
you had an opportunity
they have no idea why president he has
no idea what he's talking about here's
the deal
the fact is i will accept it and he will
too you know why
because once the winner is declared
after all the all the ballots are
counted
all the votes are counted that'll be the
end of it that'll be the end of it
and if it's me in fact fine if it's not
me
i'll support the outcome and i'll be a
president not just for the
democrats i'll be a president for
democrats and republicans
and this guy i want to say honestly
uh to be continued as in more debates as
we go on
president trump vice president biden
it's been an interesting hour and a half
i want to thank you both
for participating in the first of three
debates that you have agreed to engage
in we want to thank case western reserve
university
and the cleveland clinic for hosting
this event the next debate sponsored by
the commission
on presidential debates will be one week
from tomorrow october 7th at the
university of utah
in salt lake city the two vice
presidential nominees vice president
mike pence and senator kamala harris
will debate at 9 pm eastern that night
we hope you watch
until then thank you and good night
thank you
[Applause]
greatest president of all time
[Music]
you